[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to the
closing ceremony of the saint louis
rapid and blitz and the opening ceremony
of the sink field cup it's been quite an
interesting year we have all been
through but i think it's remarkable that
the grand chess tour managed to put on
all five events
well the fifth one coming up
successfully please give the organizer
organizers a warm round of applause
[Applause]
the rapid and blitz tournament was the
fourth stop on the grand chess tour the
sink field cup is the final stop it will
decide the winner of the entire grand
chess tour there is a hundred and
thousand dollar prize fund added to the
winners to cup winners
amount already so it's very exciting
there's some close fights
afoot and we're excited to see what
happens next i want to thank
shannon bailey and the world chess hall
of fame for hosting us as always they
make this wonderful building available
please give them a round of applause
[Applause]
of course none of this would happen
without
the generosity of two very special
people
we are always grateful for them it
cannot be said enough what they've done
to change american chess and world chess
as well and those are dr genie and rex
singfield
[Applause]
there are a number of people working
behind the scenes
they never get all the credit they
deserve some shy away from the camera as
well they just want to get the job done
and those names include gary kasparov
the brainchild behind the grand chester
mike kotakovsky uh his able right-hand
man and of course on the executive board
of
the grand chess tour theresa prisbonova
tony rich and joy bray the head
lady in charge she's one who hides from
the camera point a camera at her i want
a camera pointed directly
but thank you all so much for everything
that you do please give them a hand
we have several sponsors of course none
of it happens without our sponsors we'd
like to thank super bed and super united
vivendi chess club e4
in croatia and the st louis chess club
thank you so much
[Applause]
and we'd also like to thank our
broadcast partners keysquare and
kasparovchest.com that allow us to put
on this marvelous or these series of
marvelous events and without further ado
i will now hand
the show over to executive director of
the chess club tony rich
[Applause]
thank you so much maurice you know it's
funny during these covet times we all
have to wear masks we have our own
microphones the players even have to
play with masks on in the playing hall
it's not ideal but really this is the
return to over-the-board chess that
we've all been waiting so long for uh
early on in the grand chess tour season
just before we went to bucharest romania
there was a lot of question there were a
lot of questions still surrounding these
events whether we'd be able to get all
the players in place whether we would be
able to implement good safety and health
protocols to ensure uh successful
tournaments well i'm happy to report
that we've made it all the way to the
very last event and with a couple of
exceptions primarily related to travel
restrictions all of the players have
really been able to compete across the
entire tour and what a series of events
it's been as marie said none of it would
have been possible without all of our
great sponsors including vivendi
chess club e4
and the fine folks at superbad and super
united
i'm sure you all heard as well michael
kortakovsky the executive director of
the grand chess tour made the
announcement uh just as we finished up
in croatia that the 2022 grand chess
tour season will be bigger and better
than ever uh we're including a new stop
in warsaw poland uh that's also
sponsored by the folks at superbad and
super united so we're really excited to
add a new european capital on the tour
we'll be right back here in st louis for
the sink field cup and then the st louis
rapid and blitz returns in 2023 as well
so the grand chess tour is exciting
it'll continue to be exciting next year
and look forward to more information to
come about the future grand chess tour
events
now it is my pleasure to introduce to
you who jeanne sinkfield calls the
godfather of chess and he really is the
reason that we're all here and that
we've been able to do this now for
almost 15 years in saint louis he's
truly single-handedly transformed the
landscape of what chess in the united
states looks like
and what chess means for all of us here
the founder of the st louis chess club
rex infield
[Applause]
thank you tony it's very kind of you
first of all genie and i would like to
once again welcome all the players that
have just arrived in st louis for the
springfield cup and
the rapid and blitz this is my favorite
time of the year when the great players
come together
and uh it's also sad when the
tournaments are over and the grand
masters start leaving town
so it's an honor to have all of you here
in st louis
and you're always welcome to stay keep
that in mind i check with the mayor and
there are spaces available
okay so let's give the players a big
round of applause and welcome
[Applause]
and we are able to boast that we have
the best
commentary team in the history of sports
with grand master yasser sarawan who's
giggling
grand master maurice ashley and grand
master alejandro ramirez
[Applause]
the staff of the chess club and the
world chess hall of fame
work so well together together and do a
phenomenal job day in and day out
thanks to joy bray who runs everything
our master in chief
and tony ritz the executive director of
the club and shannon bailey the chief
curator
of the world chess hall of fame and all
their staff for everything they do
to make the organization such a great
success i would also like to thank all
the contractors and vendors
randy and his team at spectrum studios
kevin deputy his crew at silverback
and the st louis chess club production
team they all do an amazing job with the
broadcast
i have to say it was amazing to watch
hikaru dominate rapid and blitz
he played a total of 27 games
including nine rapid 18 blitz and he was
undefeated
according to chess space
this is the only time a player has gone
undefeated in a grand chess tour rapid
blitz event so carl congratulations for
an outstanding performance
now i'm happy to say you've gotten rid
of me and i turn it over to
my brother maurice
thank you rex i used to be your son but
somehow
as rex said
his result spoke
for itself
to go undefeated in a field of this many
stars
in a rapid and blitz event is simply
extraordinary we were
so impressed
as commentators as we watched in awe as
this player
time and time again
showed his incredible skill his
determination his tenacity his ability
to right the ship whenever he was in
trouble
and
just show that he's one of the best
performers at his craft
i should recognize third place finisher
richard rapport of hungary and second
place finisher fabiano caruana
however it was this man who takes over
the trophy
he won in 2018 and he does it again
the champion of the saint louis rapid
and blitz 2021 is ikaru nakamura
hey karu
please stand up and take the trophy rex
please tony
get some photos with hikaru in the
trophy
oh don't break it
please give him a big hand once again
hikaru nakamura
and as they sit hikaru you may remain
standing we asked you to say a few words
about this event and what it has meant
to you to win
yeah so um first of all once again a big
big shout out to rex and janie for
everything they've done since 2009 i
think was maybe even before then
um you know it was really nice being
back here in st louis seeing a lot of
familiar faces
and of course winning i mean certainly
was the best part but just in general it
was really nice being here and for all
the fans who
unfortunately were not able to attend
and had to watch on the internet i think
they they enjoyed it a lot as well it's
just it's great to see that chess and st
louis is thriving so thank you once
again
[Applause]
thank you hikaru and
that concludes the closing ceremony of
the saint louis rapid and blitz
and moving right along we're now going
to go into the opening ceremony of the
2021 sinfield cup
has it been eight years is this the
eighth sing philica i believe it is the
eighth
yasser we've been here since the
beginning i mean
they're gonna have to take us out of
here in a wheelbarrow
it's been an extraordinary time here
we've seen some incredible things happen
at this tournament you start with magnus
declining a draw that would have won him
the tournament
fabi
winning seven games in a row that that
still
just rings like something
impossible
uh in our minds uh we've seen
past winners uh here uh maxine vashila
grav who's sitting here with us dingler
in his tiebreak victory over magnus was
something extraordinary to see as well
we do miss lavon oronian who couldn't
get here
for visa
issues
he
had played in every single singfield cup
so it's a shame that he's not going to
play now but we have an illustrious
group of players
who will be taking up the mantle this
year and i'm sure it's going to be just
as exciting as ever if not more exciting
that's my commentator side coming out i
got a hyphen i gotta hyphen all right
well we will again of course have
my partners in crime
we have too much fun in the studio guys
they're going to stop paying us because
we're having so much fun don't do that
but
it's it's a lot of fun i like to
recognize my fellow commentators
grandmasters yasser sieron and alejandro
ramirez
[Applause]
even though when they pick uh who's
going to win it's terrible i mean
i picked takara to win and they picked
other people so
i'd also like to recognize grandmasters
janice boris who will be the production
assistant and
kosher kavutsky the sinkfield cup
journalist
and now
to introduce the players
from
one through ten we have an even split
five
tour participants and five wild cards
that means that there's going to be
five people who are going to be trying
to bring down five other people
as they try to make this
grand chester 2021 their own
i will begin at the top and introduce
you as i say your name please stand
from the united states
world number two
fabiano caruana
[Applause]
also from the united states grandmaster
wesley soh
from azerbaijan grand master chakrillar
mamadiara
[Applause]
from
france a previous winner of this event
maxime vashil grave
[Applause]
he's also a grand master by the way
from hungary grand master richard
rapport
[Applause]
from russia grand master peter svidler
[Applause]
and now a series of u.s representatives
from the usa grand master lanier
dominguez
[Applause]
the youngest player in the field from
the usa grand master jeffrey zhang
[Applause]
also from the u.s grand master sam
shankland
[Applause]
and a last-minute replacement
jumping in
with the dragons
grandmaster
darius schweitz
[Applause]
darius i'm gonna start with you
you're you were
slated as a last minute replacement how
does it feel to actually be
participating in this event which you
have no doubt followed over the years
you can take it down okay
so
it's a great honor to start with like i
never expected
that i could play this tournament
so it's a great honor definitely
yeah like i
[Music]
learned over on friday that i could
possibly play because there was some
uncertainty about some player and on
monday i was over the entire weekend
pretty nervous and
anxious what's the final outcome but in
the today in the morning i learned that
level is not making it and i was
extremely thrilled and excited to play
so yes it means a lot to me i never
played such a strong tournament ever
before so also my rating 26 50 roughly i
didn't expect to play here but i'm
really thankful for giving me the
opportunity to play here to organizers
to rex here uh to
tony to all governments from chess tour
granchester everyone involved decision
making i'm really really thankful it's a
great chance for me opportunity
i will do my best
thank you very much
for stepping up to the plate
grandmaster shanklin i will go to you
you have watched this event over the
years as well and it is your first
opportunity to play your thoughts on
having this chance
well obviously i'm totally thrilled uh
so this is now my second grand chester
event after the recently concluded rapid
and blitz i've always put a much higher
focus on classical trust which i've been
playing really well at lately and
hopeful i can keep up that good form
it's obviously a tremendous honor to be
playing among some like the very best
players in the world
and
well i'm ready to play we'll see how it
goes
thank you for that
uh
we have again i said the youngest player
in the field to have this kind of
opportunity jeffrey
your first time in the sing-fil cup as
well your thoughts
yeah uh definitely i remember um
i was just a little kid when when i uh
watched magnus refuse the draw for the
infamous
moment and uh i've been dreaming of
getting my own shot to uh to play in the
sink field cup so it's truly a surreal
feeling and
hopefully i can
show a decent performance
so if it's the last round and somebody
offers you a draw and you win the
tournament
what's your odds of saying now i'm just
gonna play
i think
we will cross that bridge
fair enough
lanier i believe you've played in this
event before or is it oh the singapore
cup okay so we have another first timer
your chance to play you've been very
close to top ten
this is a big big opportunity for you
yeah it's great uh to have the
opportunity to to play for the first
time and such a great tournament one of
the
strongest in the world for sure
and especially here in saint louis so we
had a
week of rabbit and blitz
it was really fun and everything
but of course this is a different type
of chess
which is also nice to have and
really looking forward to to the event
and
i'll do my best of course
next up richard rapport richard your
first time playing in this event it was
also your first time playing in the
saint louis rapid and blitz you played
in st louis before
uh
i think you played a match against sam
and did quite well if i remember
oh yeah actually i played in the rapid
blitz in 2019 so ah yes
i wasn't that remarkable though so
i guess that's why i forgot tell
everybody
but this event you just played and you
did extremely well coming in third place
clear third your thoughts about playing
in the sing field cup yeah i'm looking
very much forward to it um i think i
haven't played a classical on the board
tournament for a very long time
so i mean
not to mention such magnitude so i'm
just really excited and we'll see how it
goes yeah
peter
you're usually a commentator you were
supposed to be a commentator for this
these events until
your droog decided he couldn't play that
is his homeboy
in russian uh grisha
you're
you have played in this event i believe
a couple of times your feelings about
playing now
yeah i seem to be the kind of a like for
like replacement for russian players in
this tournament considering the people
i'm replacing are kramnik and grishok i
don't know how like for like that is
honestly
but it's always extremely exciting to
play here and it's a fantastic field and
i'm
very much very much looking forward to
it
indeed those
there were five wild cards and richard
uh was a tour participant we get
continue with the tour participants and
we'll start with uh chakriar
you
you did great in bucharest but the next
couple events you haven't had too much
fun but you get a chance now to get back
to what is normally your great strength
uh is classical chess where you bring up
all the creative ideas your feelings
about getting a chance to punch in the
sing-field club this year
okay
of course i played very well in
bucharest yeah after i played two
tournaments
uh
i think also very good
is
to be in top
i don't know six seven is good for me
but it's rapid i am now is not young
i not play very fast
for this reason
[Music]
i am very happy with my results in all
tournaments and
i hope i will continue in this level i
think
maxim vashilagrav
you had to sit on the side and watch
them play
the
rapid and blitz
how do you feel about how
your competitors performed and you have
won this event before you feel you have
to win again if you're going to win the
grand chess tour
um yeah i watched a lot of exciting
games
in general
as a spectator that was actually quite
nice but of course i am usually waiting
for for tomorrow
to play some good chess
win some games definitely and
we'll see how it goes
wesley you have also won this event but
it's been some time i think you won in
2016.
and uh you are now at the top of the
standings for the grand chess tour
pressure
uh no i i just want to play some some
good chefs i i think
my previous tournament didn't go very
well
but
i'm very thankful to
rex and genie and saint louis chess club
for for having this event which could
easily have been postponed and
now i think
only four players are fighting for
the top spots in the grand chester so my
suggestion is to add a fourth prize that
way
that way no one's fighting for anything
but yeah i just want to play some some
good chefs it doesn't matter if i win or
not but
avoid blenders
it does now usually i hear those words
and
you know we let you go but it doesn't
matter if you win or not can we
is that serious
yeah i think uh
as a professional chess player just want
to play some some good gifs and
whoever wins it deserves it if they play
the best chef
[Music]
i might take a poll of the the players
up here if they all agree but i'm just
going to ask one person the number two
player in the world and someone who's
won this event twice
fabi uh it doesn't matter if you win
i want to complain if i win
um yeah i i think uh i think it matters
for everyone here
um i mean everyone's going to be trying
very hard and we have a field of i think
really fighting players
um so anything can happen
you haven't had a brilliant year but
this year you had
a second place performance
in this event in those rapid blitz
upswing for you
um well it's like cautiously optimistic
but yeah the last tournament went
pretty well for me uh so that was a nice
change
all right whoa that is the players who
are playing
let us
pass this over to tony rich and he will
do the official drawings and such
right so um
we thanked a lot of people at the very
beginning of this event and uh one group
of folks who rarely get the the
attention in the spotlight in fact it is
said that the best arbiter of an event
is the one that you never see or hear
from you don't even know who they were
they were able to sit in the corner
quietly and do their job without having
to um make a big ruckus we have a great
arbiting team here in st louis really
lucky with the folks that we've had our
chief arbiter for both the saint louis
rapid and blitz and the singfield cup
his international arbiter chris byrd he
was supported in the st louis rapid and
blitz by his two deputy arbiters karen
penick and jonathan schachter and he'll
be supported in the singfield cup with
his deputy arbiter enrique huerta a big
round of applause for arbiters
[Applause]
so a little inside baseball here
well
normally chris comes up here and he
helps me with the actual drawing of lots
for the players uh drawing of lots is
where we determine the order in which
the players play each other and with
which color everybody draws a number one
through ten and we usually have some
kind of a nice gift like this for the
players as their method of drawing lots
so when chris got in this evening and he
saw the run of show and he's like hey
tony uh first of all we don't actually
have to draw lots for anybody and second
of all i'm not prepared for this so can
you go ahead and do the announcement
part of the the round one pairings happy
to cover chris no worries
uh but that's right we don't actually
have to do a drawing of lots for this
event in fact the way the grand chess
tour regulations were structured this
year in order to ensure maximum fairness
across the entire tour the sinkfield cup
pairings are colors reversed pairings
from the super bet chess classic the two
bookended classical events in this event
uh in this tour i'm sorry uh so the
singfield cup pairings are known they're
published on the website in fact the
players have been preparing probably
most of today for their rounds tomorrow
so in lieu of drawing lots instead i'll
call the players up to the stage in
their pairing
matchup order and ask them to take their
gift maybe pose for a photo and then
take their seats again so starting out
the all-america match-up between grand
masters daria spirits and linear
dominguez
come on up
[Applause]
just right in front of the table here
grab your gifts pose for a photo maybe
do one of those cool boxing poses where
you look mean mugging at each other
it's hard to see a mean mug behind a
mask but
thank you very much uh next up also an
all-american matchup between
grandmasters fabiano cariwana and sam
shanklin
[Applause]
oh yeah anyone is fine there are no
pairing numbers you can't guess wrong
now hold on you gotta post for a photo
with fabi
next up grandmasters jeffrey zhang and
richard rapport
and by the way don't forget that you can
follow all the action from the grand
chess tour on grandchester.org
including pairings and results
commentary which is streamed through our
partners at kasparov chess as well the
games begin at 3 pm each day thank you
both very much next up grand master
maxime vacher lagrave against
grandmaster peter svidler
[Applause]
see
the russians can do it
thank you both very much and last but
certainly not least the premier matchup
between grand masters wesley soh and
shakariar mahmud yarov
[Applause]
you know these guys travel a lot they
play a lot of the same tournaments
against each other in fact i bet they've
each played maybe dozens of games
against one another especially the
frequent faces up here so maybe it's
actually kind of nice that we have so
many wild cards and new folks playing in
the singfield cup this year i'm sure it
promises to delight without any further
ado further ado to wrap up the opening
closing all-around ceremony maurice
ashley
we like hostility tony
so we appreciate blood spilling on the
board and there will be a lot of blood
spilling in this event no question about
it it is an uneven feel some new faces
playing quite a few new faces in fact
and some veterans who will be vying for
a big prize
not just winning the 300 000 their share
of the 300 000 purse but also the chance
to be the 2021
grand chess tour champion that's going
to be a big deal we'll be calling all
the action join us at 10 minutes to 3
central that is 10 to 4 on the east
coast as we start our broadcast as tony
said grand chess tour dot org our
partners at casparofchess.com
as well it'll be an amazing event as
always thanks so much for joining us for
the closing ceremony of the saint louis
rapid and blitz and the opening ceremony
of the 2021 singfield cup see you guys
tomorrow have a great night
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you